Good morning John.
I'm going to tell you a story.
So when I first moved to Missoula I went to
the grocery store 'cause I was hungry and
I knew how to make tacos so I bought some
meat and some beef and...
Meat and beef?
Some beans and cheese and tortillas and stuff,
right?
And the cashier, as she's checking me out
is like "Boop.
Boop" and then she's like "So, tacos tonight?"
At this point I was around 23 years old and
I can say pretty securely that I had had,
like, zero interactions with cashiers that
weren't "Hello", "Thank you" and "Do you want
a receipt?"
So basically, I was completely freaked out,
flabbergasted, I didn't know what to say,
despite the fact that, yes, I was having tacos,
so the clear answer was yes, which I think
I finally came up with.
Having seen that I was not the kind of person
who speaks to people, she didn't push it any
further, so it turns out that I'd moved from
a place where that's not a normal thing to
a place where it was, and also, that I kinda
like it.
I mean, it used to be that I was terrified
to, like, tell the person at Wendy's what
kind of hamburger I wanted, but man, in this
town, you gotta be ready, and some people
really don't like it, but I, I quite do.
I was at Pita Pit recently, and the person
was like, "So, how's your day been?" and I
was like, "Really weird, actually!"
And they were like, "Well, that sounds interesting,"
and like, settling in for me to tell them
about it, but I was like, "But I don't have
time to tell you, I need a pita."
And then there was a time when I was at a
liquor store, oh my God, the woman looks at
my ID and she was like, "Oh my God, I would
never have thought that you were so old" and
that's a nice thing to say, I guess, and then
she was like, "The other day, we had an Asian
in here, and he looked so young, I did not
believe his ID, and he was here with his white
girlfriend" and I was just like, "I could
never imagine that, I would feel so improper".
Mind you, while there's a line, I'm not the
only person in the liquor store, and I'm like,
"Okay, miss, you clearly have issues.
I don't think I'm the person to deal with
them, so I would like to acquire my brown
liquor of some sort that you're selling to
me and take it home so that I can drink it
faster than I normally would have now that
I've had this interaction."
But mostly, I find that talking to strangers,
whether that's on the street or when we're
having some kind of commercial interaction
is very pleasant, and I like strangers, I
like talking to strangers when I'm at a shower,
at a bar, or at a club.
Is a bar and a club the same thing?
Well, anyway, when I see people on the internet
or on the news, they tend to be less nice
than the ones that I meet in real life, and
so what I'm saying is, if you wanna get an
accurate picture of the kind of quality people
exist, you gotta talk to strangers!
Which is not normal advice.
Don't get in their cars or anything.
It's also good practice.
I never was comfortable with it until I just
started doing it all the time.
The other day at Taco Bell, the woman was
like, "Good morning."
It was like, four o'clock in the afternoon,
and I was like, "Not quite."
And then I felt a little bad about it 'cause
she looked kind of embarrassed, so I was like,
"Well, don't worry about it, when I'm leaving,
you will say "enjoy your meal", and I will
say "you, too" and then I will feel the way
that you feel now."
And then, when she gave me my food, she didn't
say "Enjoy your meal", so I couldn't do the
thing, which I thought was gonna be super
funny.
There is a lot going on right now.
NerdCon: Stories is next week, so I'm very
busily prepping for that.
I have to make sure that I'm ready to do all
the things I gotta do, and of course, I've
been totally overwhelmed by the success of
the Wizard School Kickstarter, oh, so cool!
We're over 1000% funded, so we're gonna get
to make the game, but that doesn't mean that
you can't go pledge to the Kickstarter, please
do that, 'cause there are stretch goals, and
we want to hit them.
I'm going to be in Portland and Seattle with
Welcome to Night Vale if you're around those
areas, it is super fun, and I've done it before,
such a good show that these people do.
And I would also like to announce, for the
first time on this channel, our newest video
project things.
One, Engage by Uplift, a series about dealing
with abuse and sex and the weird nature of
those things in virtual spaces.
They're taking on difficult and important
topics direct to camera and in discussion
formats.
And also, The Financial Diet, which is a show
about how to live in the world as a young
person while following your dreams but not
ruining your future.
So if you're interested in any of those things,
they're all around me, you can click on them,
check them out, John, I'll see you on Tuesday.